Oh statistician at Memorial
sloan-kettering Cancer Center I've been
there for almost eight years now and in
that role I collaborate with oncologists
and surgeons and radiologists and all
other types of clinicians work in cancer
research to play on their prospective
research studies and analyze
retrospective data and it's a really fun
job I use our for that and rely very
heavily on our markdown which like saves
my life every time they're like I
changed one data point and I can just
you know run my reports again so I will
be talking today about some survival
analysis stuff kind of introducing the
topic and talking about ways that it
survival time data is commonly
misinterpreted or Mis analyzed and some
of the ways you can use are to do it
correctly okay so the most common type
of data I encounter in my work at a
cancer hospital is survival time data
and survival time data is any type of
data that has a start time so in the
work I do that's commonly a date of
diagnosis or a date of treatment start
or a date of surgery and then some
amount of time passes and there's an end
date at which an event of interest
occurs and so in the work I do that's
commonly death or a disease recurrence
or disease progression and there's a
date associated with that so it's kind
of obvious that this type of data would
be common and so in in cancer research
or in any other fields of healthcare
research but it's actually common across
many fields and kind of sometimes I
think it can be a little sneaky and so
people don't know they're dealing with
data that has a time component but in
other healthcare fields like
cardiovascular research and hiv/aids
this is common it's also very common in
social science research there's a lot of
social science endpoints that actually
have a time component your event is
happening and maybe today you ask
someone a question and the answer is no
but the answer could be yes tomorrow or
next week or next month and so this time
component is important to consider and
it's very very commonly analyzed
incorrectly so like I just mentioned
survival analysis is common in a lot of
different fields and so that means it
goes by a lot of different names and we
call it in healthcare survival analysis
most of the time sometimes time to event
analysis but it can also be known as
reliability analysis duration and
alysus or event history analysis and so
these are just some terms you can watch
out for that could clue clue you in that
there's a time component to something
that you're reading about um you guys
the my clock number started so just FYI
I'm gonna talk for 20 minutes but okay
so in cancer there are kind of two main
questions that are commonly of interest
to patients so one of the main things
that we do is we analyze data and the
goal is often to generate some numbers
that doctors use to convey prognostic
information to their patients so it's
really important to get this right and
two of the most common things that
quantities that are of interest are the
probability of surviving a certain
number of years so this could be one
year or five years or ten years and then
some estimate of like on you know on
average how long do people with a
certain disease tend to live so just a
very simple example to start we have
five patients here and we're interested
in let's say we're interested in the
5-year probability of survival well
patients one three four and five we're
all followed for the full five years
they were alive at the end of that five
year follow-up and then their patient
who died at three years so this is
pretty straightforward we can just take
the proportion of patients who died one
out of five and estimate the 5-year
probability of survival of 80% so no
problem here this is straightforward so
the problem comes in and the complexity
comes in when that's not exactly the
case so in the same simple example I've
altered the data for two patients so we
still have patients one in four who are
followed for a full five years and
they're alive at the end of follow-up
patient two died at three years but now
patients three and five have been
followed for less than five years and
the last thing that we knew about them
is that they were alive and this can
this is what's known as censored data
and this can occur for a lot of reasons
it can happen because patients enter a
study late and so then the study ends
and they haven't been followed for the
full amount of time of interest or it
can happen because they entered at the
beginning but for some reason they were
lost to follow-up maybe they moved out
of the area or some other reason
it's very common to have this kind of
variation and survival time data and
then in follow-up data and then you know
we want to estimate the five-year
probability of survival but for patients
three and five in this example at five
years we don't know if they were dead or
alive all we know is that at some point
in time before five years the last thing
we know about them is that they were
alive so now it's not so straightforward
to get these estimates so I'm gonna be
using an example today throughout my
talk before I get into some R code and
some results it's a kidney cancer data
there's 2119 patients in this data sets
a retrospectively sampled and we're
interested the event of its wrist is
just death from any cause so we're
interested in overall survival so I'm
going to be using two main our packages
the first is the survival package and
the survival package has all of the
functions that you need to estimate
quantities associated with survival and
do regression models with sensor data in
R and then the second package I'll be
talking about is the serve minor package
which is a great package for visualizing
survival data that uses ggplot in the
background so just to take a look at a
little bit of the couple of the
functions that we rely on so in this
data set that I'm using as an example
there are only a few variables in there
one is a time variable and so this is a
variable that's calculated from our
start date in this example date of
surgery to the end date which is the
date of death for patients who died or
the date of censoring for patients who
were last known to be alive and this is
the variable I'm calling OS years and
then there's an indicator variable which
is one if the patient died and zero
otherwise and these are the two main
variables we need to do our survival
analysis so you'll see in that first
line of code we have inside the inside
surface we have a formula the left-hand
side of the formula is the serve
function which takes two arguments the
first is the time variable and the
second is the indicator and then the
right-hand side of the equation is just
one because I'm just interested in the
overall survival right now and then
surfeit is the function that generates
our survival curve and the rest of that
code is just plotting stuff
the GD serv plat function is the mean
function from the serve miner package
that does this nice plotting so we have
this survival curve now
and it's a step function actually every
point in time where an event occurs
there's a down step so if multiple
events occur at one time there will be a
larger step down and it's the shaded
area around it as a 95% confidence
interval we have on the x-axis our years
from surgery and the y-axis is our
survival probability from 0 to 1 you can
see below the plat I up also included a
table of the number at risk and this is
important because you can see at time 0
it's our full sample size of 2119 but as
that time goes on patients die and
patients are censored and we have fewer
patients left in our analytics set and
so those estimates start to be a little
more uncertain and it's good to keep
track of kind of how many patients are
going into any estimate you're making so
if you're trying to make inference out
at 15 years you can see that you're not
as sure about what those numbers are
because we only have 27 patients often
our data at that point okay so going
back to those two main quantities that I
said are of interest it to convey
prognostic information to patients let's
say we're interested in the 5-year
probability of survival so we can get
this from our surf adoption object by
passing it to the summary and we have an
additional argument that's x you can
supply a vector of x I'm only interested
in 5 right now so I've just said 5 and
what this is is it's the point on the y
axis the survival probability that
corresponds to where that survival curve
is at five years and we find in this
example that our 5-year probability of
survival is 81% so this is the quantity
that is commonly calculated incorrectly
you'll see this in the literature all
the time if someone doesn't know there's
a time component to their data or
doesn't know the right way to analyze it
a common way to estimate this
incorrectly is just to do what we did in
our simple example where there wasn't
any censoring and say in this example we
had 297 patients who were dead at five
years the denominator would be the full
sample size 2119 and you would estimate
that you have an 86% 5-year probability
of survival and you see that you get an
overestimate here because it's ignoring
the fact that 968 patients were actually
censored before that five year point so
five years for those 968 patients we
don't actually know if they're dead or
alive and so just putting them in
the denominator like that will result in
an over estimate of your of your
survival probability the second quantity
that's of interest is the some estimate
of the time the average time that
patients survive and we get this from a
median survival time which you can
obtain just by printing out your surfeit
object and what the median survival time
is is it corresponds to the point on
your x-axis your time axis at which
there's a 50% survival probability
according to your survival curve and in
this example we find that that is 12
point 7 years so this is another
quantity that's very commonly calculated
incorrectly and you'll see this in the
literature all the time and I have
doctors come to me all the time with
these numbers and they you know they're
like oh I've calculated it myself no you
haven't but um so the way this is this
is commonly incorrectly calculated as
just to take the patients who died at
the fore so in this example we have 476
patients who died and to just estimate
the median time but that it took you
know before they died and in this
example you would say that the median
survival time was 3.5 years now you can
see that as a severe under estimate of
our twelve point seven years that we get
when we analyze this correctly and so
making these kinds of mistakes in your
data can have you know bad consequences
in terms of communicating this
information to patients and this occurs
because this calculation ignores the
fact that censored patients also
contribute follow-up time right so if a
patient was censored at ten years we
don't just throw out their data and say
oh it doesn't tell us anything about
median survival time right because you
might not know how long it was until
that patient died but you know that they
lived for ten years and so that
information has to contribute to your
estimate of this median survival time
so another thing that is commonly of
interest in a survival analysis is to
compare survival curves between groups
and in this kidney cancer data that I'm
talking about our mean question of
interest was actually whether there was
an association between BMI and survival
and this question was of interest
because it's well known that BMI is a
risk factor for kidney cancer so being
overweight or obese is a risk factor for
getting kidney cancer
but among patients who have kidney
cancer it's been observed that actually
being overweight or obese is associated
with a better prognosis and this is an
idea that's known as the obesity paradox
and it's it's common across many
diseases and it's being studied a lot
right now so we just wanted to look at
this question in our own data so you can
see that my code is pretty similar here
except in the first line on the
right-hand side of the equation now I
have a variable for BMI it's a
categorical variable with three levels
for normal weight overweight and obese
and now on my survival plot I have three
curves the purple one is obese the
orange is overweight and the green is
normal the risk table at the bottom has
three rows one for each of my groups and
now you can see there's been a p-value
added to this plot and this p-value
comes from the log-rank test there are
many other ways of testing the
differences between survival curves but
I think the log-rank test is probably
the most common and what it does is it
equally weights across the whole
follow-up time to test the differences
between those survival curves and there
are versions of this test that could
also weight more heavily the early or
the late parts of follow up if there was
some reason that that was more of
interest for your question and this
p-value comes from the served if
function in R which you can just pass
your formula to that to obtain this
p-value and so in this case we do find a
significant p-value so we would conclude
that in our data the BMI is associated
with survival and by looking at the
curves it there is evidence that the
overweight and the obese groups have
their curves shifted up and so they do
seem to have better prognosis and our
data another way of testing for
differences between groups is to fit a
regression model we would a common
regression model that would be used for
this as a semi parametric model known as
the Cox regression model it there are
also a many parametric for
of regression models available for
sensor data but I'm not going to get
into those today so we would do this
using the Cox pH function so similar
syntax is what we saw before using
surfeit and commonly you would want to
do a regression model like this because
you would be interested in a multi
variable model you can imagine that in
survival analysis there are many
variables that are associated with time
to death it easily comes to mind at the
age and sex or variables that are
associated with how long people live and
so if you wanted to say something about
a variable you would want to adjust for
these important confound errs I'm just
showing a simple example here focusing
on the BMI still so if we print out a
summary of our Cox regression model fit
we would get regression parameters and
if we exponentiate those we end up with
a hazard ratio and when you're dealing
with a categorical variable like BMI you
have to have a reference group so one of
the groups has to be fixed at one and
then your other hazard ratios are in
reference to that and a hazard is an
instantaneous probability of death and
then a hazard ratio is the ratio of two
different hazards and hazard ratio
greater than one represents an increased
hazard and an hazard ratio less than one
represents a reduced hazard and you can
see here that both our overweight and
obese groups have hazard ratios less
than one suggesting that they have
reduced hazards of death compared to the
normal weight group and our p-value is
the same as it was before okay so what
really is a hazard ratio though so
they're kind of hard like oh
instantaneous hazard of death well what
does that mean hazard ratios are very
commonly misinterpreted and the most
common misinterpretation that I see is
we focus on our example comparing the
obese to the normal weight group the
hazard ratio was 0.64 and you'll
commonly see an interpretation of this
as a thirty six percent reduced risk of
death but hazard ratios aren't really
risks so we can kind of get an idea of
why this estimate of a thirty six
percent reduced risk of death doesn't
make sense in our data by looking back
at our survival curve and the first
thing to think about is the fact that
these curves are somewhat parallel and
they're all going down so what does a
thirty six percent reduced risk of death
mean for one of these groups and
text and the second thing to think about
is that if we look back at our five-year
and ten-year estimates for the normal
weight and obese groups we see that
those estimates only differ by about 11
to 12 percent and so again that doesn't
really correspond to a 36 percent
reduced risk of death
so this is a common misinterpretation of
a hazard ratio I see personally I think
they're hard to interpret and I like to
use Cox regression models to understand
directions of effects in multi variable
models and significance and multi
variable models but I like to use these
other quantities to convey and for more
information about actual differences
between groups so the last topic I'm
going to cover is conditional survival
so one of the amazing thing that's going
on in camps or research right now is
that treatments are improving people are
living longer and longer we have more
targeted treatments and more
immunological and patients are being
cured and so now it's of interest to ask
the question well does that five your
probability of survival that we
estimated at the time of surgery or
whatever your start time was we
estimated 81% in this example does that
really still apply to a patient who's
already lived for one year or five years
or 10 years you know and they still want
to know something about what their
prognosis is well the answer is no but
we can quickly and easily correct for
this by estimating a conditional
survival estimate and this is the only
formula I'm showing in my talk today and
it's just division so don't don't worry
too much about it but the s represents
the kaplan-meier estimate of survival
and if Y is our number of additional
years of interest and X is the number of
years a patient has already survived we
can simply divide the kaplan-meier
survival estimate for the total amount
of time by the kaplan-meier survival
estimate for the number of years a
patient has already survived to get a
conditional estimate and if we do this
in our example the table on the
left-hand side has the number of years
already survived from 0 through 4 and
then we're interested in the probability
of surviving to 5 years so for someone
at baseline at time 0 that's our
estimate of 81 percent of surviving for
five years at four years this would be
the probability of just surviving one
additional
and you can see that these estimates of
survival go up as time goes by and we
can also see this by the plot of
conditional survival estimates where
each color represents an additional year
survived and we can see that these
survival curves are just shifted up as
the time goes on and so it's important
to be able to update these survival
estimates if you're giving this
information to a patient who's already
lived for three years
what now what's their probability of
surviving to five years so just a quick
plug for a little R package I have that
does this it's called conserv it's
available on my github page and there's
a tiny tiny link to the bottom of it on
this slide and these calculations are
really straightforward but my package
will give you these estimates and these
plots and if you ever want to do this
it's a nice little easy way to do it so
that's all I have for you today my code
and data and slides are all available on
github so you can play around with this
it's if it's of interest and just gonna
leave you with some contact information
and also of reference to the original
publication of the kidney and BMI data
that I talked about that today so thank
you very much
you
you